Hey, it’s Thankful Thursday
and I believe that it’s important to thank the people
and companies who have had an impact on your life
on your business because you can’t do this all alone.
You need help, you need people to lift you up
and support you and so I make these videos once a week
to thank the people in my life who are having an impact
and I hope you’ll reach out to your contacts
and thank them, just give them some recognition.
So today I want to thank Sage Software.
And Sage, they make accounting software
and you may think
‘Sage accounting software, why are you thanking them?’
They used to be a client and I did some social media work with them
and I haven’t talked to them for a while
and I recently touched base
and I’ve been so impressed with what they’re doing in social media.
Most companies, they blast out coupon codes
and marketing and “We just launched our new product.
Everybody come and buy it!”
and as a result you get zero engagement because nobody cares about that stuff.
That’s not what social media is all about.
And Sage, these guys get it.
You go to Sage’s page, they’re talking about;
they recognize other customer who just got into whole foods
and they’re tweeting pictures about them
they’re recognizing people on their team who had a birthday
and they’re showcasing what they did to their cubicle at the company
they’re sharing inspirational quotes, they’re sharing articles
they have nothing to do with accounting
but will help entrepreneurs grow their businesses.
They’re trying to be a resource.
This is what’s important about social media.
You’re not out there just broadcasting and selling.
The point of social media is to build relationships with customers
and these guys – they actually care about their customers.
Imagine that, a big company that actually cares about their customers.
Now I’m fortunate to work with a number of different big brands
who have that same mindset and same philosophy
and I work with them on their campaigns.
But most companies aren’t like that
and it’s so refreshing to see a company like Sage stepping up
and doing it and bucking a trend
and I’m sure whoever is running their campaigns there are facing
you know, internal criticism or external criticism to say
“Hey, this is how you’re supposed to do it”
but they’re getting results and building a strong community
and that’s what social media is all about.
So thank you Sage for your leadership and inspiration
and for helping the entrepreneur community.
And for all of you watching, take 5 minutes today
to thank somebody who’s had an impact on your business
on your life somehow.
Send an email, write a note, take somebody out to coffee
make a video if you want to, it doesn’t have to be complex
just say thank you.
They’ll feel better, you’ll feel better
and you brighten everybody’s day.
Believe.
You guys liked this video, thumbs-up below.
If you want to support me, click on the support link in the description
and leave a comment. I’d love to hear from you.
Thank you so much, see you soon.